l'espace naturel qui longe les 25
kilomètres de la route du volcan font
partie de ce que la réunion un
d'exceptionnel depuis les années 2000 le
conseil général a mis en place une
action de réaménagement de ses espaces
naturels sensibles et la visite commence
par le piton sec
on a créé en fait des est ce qu'on
appelle des loges il ya des petites
zones comme ça assez intimiste qui
permettent d'accueillir des groupes
notamment des groupes familiaux et que
les gens puissent se retrouver comme ça
dans un petit coin de nature agréable et
après les pâturages le site d'aulnay de
bleu a été repensé une étape de plus
dans ce voyage vers l'origine de la
terre le voyage qu'on propose aux
visiteurs de remonter le temps du
volcanisme anciens jusqu'aux volcanisme
le plus actif
donc on est sur le point de vue du nez
de boeuf le premier effondrement en fait
un qui date de trois cent mille ans est
en fête
c'était fondremand ensuite s'est
transformé en valait donc une vallée la
vallée de la rivière des remparts
c'est un point de vue spectaculaires
émotionnel et c'est ça qu'on veut
provoquer chez le visiteur les aires de
pique nique seront également aménagés
afin de rendre ces espaces accessibles à
tous et en toute sécurité
ce point de vue va être conservé on va
en créer en fait à un deuxième juste au
dessus sur un petit éperon rocheux qui a
juste au dessus où la vue est encore
plus plongeante et tout ça est relié en
fait un parking bus qui va être créée
puisque le problème qu'on rencontre au
nez de boeuf qui est un des points
d'arrêts d'attractivité touristique
important sur la route du volcan il ya
beaucoup de groupes en bus qui s'arrête
et aujourd'hui s'arrête pas dans les
bonnes conditions de sécurité des
chemins symbolisée par des dalles seront
le fil conducteur de ces étapes comme si
de commerçants ou encore la plaine des
sables et si le temps le permet le pas
de bellecombe fini en beauté cette
balade initiatique
là on est dans les formations
géologiques les plus récentes
c'est vraiment un projet d'ensemble pour
avoir une cohérence globale
de découverte pour que les visiteurs
puissent comprendre et s'approprier ce
site du volcan et je crois que quand les
visiteurs comprennent ils peuvent
comprendre la valeur des lieux et le
protéger à leur tour chaque année 400
mille personnes viennent admirer ce lieu
ces aménagements écotouristique
permettront à terme d'améliorer
l'attractivité de notre volcan et de
conforter son développement